yes michael what is so urgent david
guess who i am sitting here dressed as
i'm not going to guess you could tell me
or i will hang up i will give you a hint
his last name is christ
he is the power of flight
he can heal leopards michael i am jesus
david and you know why because phyllis a
woman
has you slurped my role as santa michael
what this is a very very bad time really
what's going on
stephanie can you hop off please sure
david
what the hell how rude does she do that
all the time
do you want me on this call too michael
hey where get off
get off the phone
david
oh
michael are we all set
isn't
our interview tomorrow
yes
i just happened to be in the
neighborhood thought i'd drop in say
hello just happened to be in midtown
manhattan
thought i'd catch a show
a million a workday no
you know what
since i'm here let me ask you a few
questions about the job okay um
how many people are you interviewing
you're only interviewing branch managers
and some lower level company people ah
well good
out of curiosity are you interviewing
anyone who has been here longer than i
have or manages more people i don't
think so great one more
question when you merged those branches
who did you put in charge i believe we
put
you in george all right no further
questions okay okay i am really looking
forward to our interview and i'm really
looking forward to working with you
i have got it made in the shade i know
this company the other branch managers
are total morons hey pam yeah i forgot
what day the interview was and i drove
to new york accidentally be like three
hours late
today's a big day my presence has been
requested by
chief
chief
financial officer
david wallace
he says that he wants to talk about big
picture stuff
and i'll be honest i have
little or no idea what that means so
probably bad
so listen michael
your brands have been doing great lately
and your sales staff is reporting very
strong numbers
outperforming last year in fact um and i
don't know
exactly how to put this
but
what
are you doing
right
right what utica albany all the other
branches are struggling but your branch
is reporting strong numbers
look you're not our most traditional guy
but clearly something you are doing
is right and
i just i need to get a sense of what
that is
david here it is my philosophy is
basically this
and this is something that i live by
and i always have and i always will
don't ever
for any reason do anything to anyone
for any reason
ever no matter what
no matter
where
or who or who you are with
or or where you are going or
or where you've been
ever
for any reason whatsoever sometimes i'll
start a sentence and i don't even know
where it's going i just hope i find it
along the way
like an improv conversation
improvisation
this is going to sound sort of high
maintenance but could we have it like
three degrees cooler in here i always
think better when it's cooler
here's the thing michael is doing
something right and in this economic
climate no method of success can be
ignored it's not really time for
executives to start getting judgmental
now it's hail mary time hey
what say we order up some pasta
let's say we do
so i was in the office
when i look over
to our accounting division and there's
kevin malone kevin is wearing
a jacket that i've never seen before and
i call over to kevin kevin
is that a tweed
jacket and he looks at me and he says
michael yes it is a tweed jacket and i
look back at him and i say
i feel the need
the need for tweed
it's hard to try and evaluate yourself
michael but i appreciate you trying
and thanks for coming in oh
thank you yes i have to say i am so
impressed with the potential you see in
me
yeah
okay
yeah finish it
it's hard for me to imagine a scenario
where meredith palmer keeps her job and
david wallace does not no offense
meredith no i get it i'll call him i'll
call david no you won't because he's not
picking up his phone yes i will because
i always know how to get through to him
he told me where his kids go to school
i call the school i tell them i'm a
pediatrician
they pass me through to a secretary i
use my little girl voice
but a bing bada boom
hey sweetie what is it it's not sweetie
it's michael scott
what the hell stephanie could you hop
off please michael
i have never david
david you are on speakerphone with the
entire branch and the warehouse
hey david hey dave how are you happy
holidays
sabre is changing everything
site blockers
they don't let us use cups so i started
thinking who could handle this who would
know what to do
david wallace would know what to do
what should i do david wallace
i don't know what can you do
exactly what are you thinking
it's a tough one it is a tough one i
don't have any ideas for you then yeah
but one would be good
hey oh okay wait okay
i want to tell you about a business idea
i have
okay okay you know how kids leave their
toys everywhere okay
so this
is a vacuum it's like a shopback type of
thing
teaches kids how to pick up their own
toys
right baseball gloves uh hacky sacks
drumsticks nah
fix it up so the kid's making the noise
pick it up no no no no that's the that's
the vacuum nose okay
you you know like no
no no it's okay another guy from dunder
mifflin arnie from research he's going
to drop the prototype
and uh
it's like a shop bag
say that yep
ryan cost thunder mifflin hundreds of
thousands of dollars michael ryan david
i don't care if ryan murdered his entire
family he is like a son to me do you
realize what you're asking for here
you're talking about salary plus health
benefits and dental this time insurance
taxes social security for three people
this is a heck of a lot more than 60
grand you're talking about a
multi-million dollar buyout these are
our demands
your company cannot be worth that much
our company is worth nothing that's the
difference between you and i
business isn't about money to me david
if tomorrow my company goes under i will
just start another paper company and
then another and another and another i
have no shortage of company names
michael that's one of them
yes
these are our demands this is what we
want
our balls are in your court
yeah david wallace is on the line for
you thank god david hello we need your
help michael is everyone okay oh
well i'm afraid not toby flenderson
of hr has made a sudden reappearance
i don't understand is anyone hurt
not on the surface no but i can tell
people are disturbed david michael
you texted me 9-1-1 call me all in caps
do you know what 9-1-1 means i learned a
while back that if i don't text 9-1-1
people will not return my calls
but now people always return my calls
because
they think that something horrible has
happened
toby was hired back because he knows the
branch he was available and i like him
okay and that's that with all due
respect david this hardly seems like a
dialogue that's because it isn't michael
now what i'm curious about is how you
were able to go an entire week without
knowing a member of your staff was there
i did not want to go back to the annex
because that is where holly worked whom
i loved also it's icky back there that's
true people say it's icky
okay
i have to go david wait
no is there no way we can get rid of him
not without cause michael i have cause
it is because i hate him
you have to get along with toby no yep i
don't goodbye michael
don't do that
you